[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show as
we covered earlier on in the week
Jeffrey Epstein was found dead in his
cell of an apparent suicide putting
aside any speculation about whether it
really was or was not a suicide this is
a guy who was extremely well-connected
and we are now starting to hear really
about sort of the scope of his
connections both involving the child sex
trafficking and political connections
and other associates and we're learning
about any number of people assistants
that were involved in the sex
trafficking piece of it and of course
even would with Epstein dead it would be
great for those people to be held
accountable there are both employees and
associates that facilitated what Epstein
allegedly did they contacted victims
they scheduled sexual encounters they
are listed in documents as employee with
numbers employee one employee two etc
assistants are not named in the
documents but are known to exist
there are also all sorts of folks
including some notable ones like one
example being les Wexner les Wexner is
an extremely wealthy business dude who
was the founder of Elle brands which
includes Victoria's Secret and Bath and
Body Works and Wexner has said oh yeah
Epstein was personally managing my money
at one point in time and and served as a
trustee of the Wexner Foundation which
is a massive charitable group and I even
know people who are involved with some
of the charitable projects of the Wexner
Foundation so this is a very very long
list Alan Dershowitz is on the list
Prince Andrew we know about two
presidents Donald Trump and Bill Clinton
and I think what's important here Pat is
that we not sort of conflates we
shouldn't conflate an associate to
someone that was involved financially
with Epstein
two people that we have reason to
believe like Donald Trump were actually
involved in the sexually predatory stuff
it's all different it all needs to be
looked at separately and there are
drastically varying degrees of evidence
with a lot of these different people
yeah and with all these names being
floated out there like les Wexner and
Jeffrey I know I'm sorry alan dershowitz
and the president's a prince Andrew it's
easy to conflate them all together and
put them into one pool but you know many
of those people severed their ties with
with epstein at a certain point be it 5
10 15 years ago and so we have to take a
look at all those individual cases
individually same thing with like the
me2 movement stuff that went on about a
year and a half ago at this point and I
think that's important to do at the same
time there's definitely some some fishy
stuff here like les Wexner had Jeffrey
Epstein managing his money and his
philanthropic work but Epstein didn't
really have a background and that stuff
so it's hard to imagine that the first
line or the first few clients that he
would take on is someone who's so rich
and powerful and well-connected also the
Alan Dershowitz thing it's kind of weird
to see Dershowitz respond to the
allegations made against them apparently
he was accused of receiving a massage
from an underage girl and in response he
claimed that it was actually from an old
Russian lady and that he kept his
underwear on the entire time which is
getting kind of oddly specific
there's the Bill Clinton trips that a
period parent Lee took with Jeffrey
Epstein Clinton's team said that it was
only four times but apparently it was
over 20 times so yeah it's all very
interesting I think we'll learn more
about it in the coming weeks and months
but what we do know is that Jeffrey
Epstein apparently kept very meticulous
records and had cameras installed and in
some of the facilities where some of
these acts went on so I wouldn't be
surprised if there's even video evidence
of some of this stuff and it makes sense
because for blackmail purposes if he
wants to stay connected to these people
and stay in power it would make sense
that he would want to keep records and
tabs on them now that it's been a few
days what do you think about suicide
versus murder at this point I am leaning
on the side of suicide because I think
that
this happens kind of frequently like if
you have these like rich powerful people
go to jail and they realize that this is
the end of the road for them there's no
way out there totally disgraced they're
not gonna you know have any future it's
very common to see those people commit
suicide it happened with Aaron Hernandez
the former Patriots tight end a couple
years ago that guy Ariel Castro I think
his name was the the man I think is from
Florida who kept women chained up in his
basement for like over a decade or so it
might have been Ohio but yeah I remember
that case you're talking about
yeah like within a few weeks of him
getting arrested put in jail he
committed suicide so this is a very
common thing and I think Occam's razor
just tells me it was suicide also I mean
people points the fact that you know he
was just on suicide watch or that he was
just he just committed suicide about a
month ago so you'd think that they would
you know be paying closer attention to
him but he wasn't it him to aside
attempted to commit suicide a month ago
now a divorce Yeah right
yes but like he wasn't on suicide watch
at the time so I think that it stands
the reason that he could have tried it
again and succeeded the second time one
of the things I read was that the reason
he was taking off taken off of suicide
watch was at the urging of his attorneys
because being on suicide watch comes
with such strict limitations although I
don't know I'm hoping we eventually just
get a straight answer about that issue
but in any case just a horrible horrible
series of events and allegations and we
will see what we know three months from
now about all of this as documents and
other stuff continues to come out a
federal regulators put out a warning
earlier this week that people should not
drink a solution of chlorine dioxide
that is often promoted online as a
remedy for autism hiv/aids cancer and
other conditions we're basically talking
about bleach here and in 2010 the FDA
actually said this is a very similar
solution to industrial bleach this is
really bad for you you will have severe
nausea you will vomit you will have low
blood blood pressure you can become
dehydrated it can have effects on
eyesight I believe in some cases and
apparently this is a thing that is being
promoted online as possibly a cure for
all sorts of different conditions my
initial reaction to this stuff pat is
always how can people be so dumb and
then I sort of pull back from that and
become more kind of like empathetic and
understanding about in desperate
situations people who maybe are from
certain I don't know socioeconomic
backgrounds they're just looking for
help and solutions we have a disastrous
health care system in our country where
maybe people can't get like real actual
professional care so they look stuff up
I mean I don't know I don't know but
this is just horrible horrible horrible
yeah I think it's a sign of the times in
a sense maybe it has to do in part with
the fact that some of the gatekeepers
that we used to have in like the
information world and like the health
and medicine world are gone now
because of the internet because people
can look up YouTube videos of people
recommending you drink something similar
to bleach to cure your cancer or your
autism and and people will just go along
with it because there's no easy way to
check whether or not it's true or they
just want to believe that it's true so
they go ahead and do it it's not like
the olden times where you had to just
rely on the advice of your doctor and
and maybe if you were to look into this
stuff on your own you would find it in
maybe like a medical journal or
something that was a little bit more
peer-reviewed and then yeah I think this
is something that is gonna keep popping
up these these trends continue we see
like you know well those challenges
every now and then people eating Tide
Pods it's just it's just crazy stuff but
it's not at all surprising it's never
even been remotely interesting I mean
we're now getting on to something else
but I've talked about this before like
you know eating paste or dirt as a kid
or like trying weird things I never had
that curiosity and I'm not equate emot--
lee to be clear but I do think that
there may be some kind of aside from
circumstances that we're talking about
there may be some kind of personal
personality predisposition to even being
open to stuff like this that might be
related to in some way the people who
were like yeah I'll eat some soap or
whatever I don't know it sounds kind of
interesting yeah maybe it is intuitive
in a sense because soap and bleach and
all these products they clean your
household items
they clean your kitchen right they clean
your bathroom well see they can use your
body yeah well that's true well it's so
soap cleans the outside of your body
right maybe they think that it can also
clean the inside of your body and
release the the harmful toxins that's
going on in there yeah that might be I
mean I were sort of joking but I think
that there probably is some underlying
philosophical thread through all of this
stuff it's it's weird but it's tragic
don't drink bleach don't drink this
stuff this is bad it won't cure or help
with any condition whatsoever the Trump
administration is moving forward with
these regulations that will have a major
impact on the immigration system because
they will they're attempting to in-state
a policy where a green card or visa can
be denied to immigrants who use or are
expected to use a whole bunch of
different benefits ranging from food
stamps to Medicaid and housing vouchers
and the idea here is to start
effectively targeting people that the
administration believes are going to
cost more than others by virtue of their
presence in the United States and to use
that as a justification to the deny them
immigration status now my hope is that a
court would find this illegal and the
basis on which it would be found illegal
is that it is putting in place a sort of
barometer or criteria for immigration
that goes beyond what is in the law and
then it just becomes a question of well
can the administration modify what's in
the law as of right now this is a policy
this is a public charge policy and as
such it would be subject to judicial
review but every time we talk about this
pad and we say well hopefully the courts
will get it right increasingly the
courts are made up of judges that Donald
Trump has appointed to on the Supreme
Court
25% in climbing of superior and
appellate courts so increasingly like
with every passing month
we literally can't rely on the idea that
eventually courts are gonna do the right
thing yeah and this may have to go
through the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
and if it does then that would be a
little bit more
on our side because that tends to be a
little bit more liberal but certainly
some of the other district courts are
more conservative and if it gets up to
the Supreme Court who knows what would
happen because conservatives do have a
slim majority there yeah I'm worried
especially about the unintended
consequences of this because if you have
visa applicants or people who have green
cards in the country they may fear
signing up for some of these welfare
programs because they would be worried
that it would affect their legal status
here in the United States and maybe
instead of you know getting SNAP
benefits they'll decide not to and some
of them could go hungry or you know
instead of signing up for Medicaid they
will decide not to because they worry
that that would kind of put into
jeopardy their legal status here so I'm
very worried about that stuff and also I
think there would be the unintended
consequences of causing more
undocumented immigrants because people
would want to fly under the radar if
they realize that if they try to go
through the legal means of getting into
the country but they don't have the
financial means to necessarily support
themselves then maybe the best option
for them is to go into the country
undocumented instead of through the like
the legal immigration process well it's
so short-sighted in that if you consider
that again the idea is that they would
determine whether someone's likely to
use benefits in some cases so it
wouldn't actually even be based on
whether you are actually using benefits
but what we know is that if someone
doesn't have food stamps and they don't
have money for food they become more
likely to commit a crime to get that
food or to steal money to get the food
so are we really actually better off
because there's a huge societal cost to
that if people don't go on Medicaid
because they're worried if they go on
Medicaid they may lose their legal
status if they get hurt or they have an
illness or symptoms they will use the
emergency room as their primary care
provider which is expensive and it's one
of the reasons we pay from us so much
for health care so it's so short-sighted
in that way yeah and I also think this
is going to the the [ __ ] countries
comment that Trump made that we want
people from Norway and Sweden and we all
want people for Mexico and Guatemala
because you know people in those
northern European countries tend to have
more money just where the based on where
like the currency value is and what cost
of living is like in those countries
so maybe they would be able to better
afford coming to the United States
whereas someone from Latin America may
not be able to because of the the
currency valuation and what the cost of
living is down there and so I think that
this would lead to more immigrants
coming here from Europe and and fewer
coming from Hispanic America Latin
America were from Africa and I think
that's exactly what Trump and
Republicans want yeah that's a feature
of this idea rather than a bug and we'll
see hopefully again a court ultimately
hopefully it doesn't go forward as
proposed if it does hopefully it will be
challenged in court and if it is
hopefully a court will make the right
decision about this but increasingly we
simply can't count on that on that on
that because it is they eight rumpus
judiciary with every passing day week
and month it is a judiciary nationally
made up more and more of people that
Donald Trump has selected that does it
for today new show new bonus show
tomorrow the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]